all flights canceled out of the airport
after thousands of pro-democracy
protesters occupied the terminal it's
the latest round of protests in the city
after opposition to proposed extradition
laws grew into wider unrest against
police brutality and Hong Kong's rulers
in Beijing the airport was forced to
cancel all departures as well as
arrivals which weren't already on route
after thousands of people occupied the
arrivals hall as you can see many of
them were eye patches now the reason for
that was because a young girl had
received an injury to her eye tear gas
around fire by police thoughts are that
she may lose her sight in the last hour
the airport said check-in desks won't
reopen until at least tomorrow morning
our chief of course monitor at Ramsey is
at the airport for us it looks pretty
peaceful Stuart okay it's just got a bit
unpeaceful we're not really quite sure
what's happened somebody is being taken
out there appears to be neither a vital
or some type of
something that dirt has taken place and
we saw the protesters move up the
escalators and stairs here and as you
can see he's slightly a bit away from us
and he's being led away we're not quite
sure why the last flight we believe has
arrived at the airport and that sort of
meant to be the end of the protest which
has completely closed this airport apart
from those last flights that were in the
air from long distances now there are no
outgoing flights at all at the moment
but the incoming ones they had to let in
because obviously it's they've flown
from the United States and from Europe
there are huge numbers of people still
here
we'll take you this one as you say it is
pretty peaceful as a rule and they've
been here since Friday just sitting on
the ground and making their protest what
happened as you were alluding to earlier
was very violent night last night we
were in it was pretty hardcore by any
rioting standards but by Hong Kong
standards it was absolutely off the
Richter scale and we saw the police
firing into the metro and we saw this
young lady hit in the eye with a tear
gas canister she might lose that eye
that calls huge hunters people to come
back to this demonstration that's been
going on since Friday and adding to the
numbers there were so many here by the
middle of the day they basically as I
said like the
simply can't operate and so it was
utterly closed down what happens now we
don't know the protesters and we solve
many thousands thousands upon thousands
leaving because they said the police
were coming it's hard to imagine they're
going to storm an International Airport
but they are losing their patience so
they may what will happen with these
people are here we're not quite certain
about they could start leaving very
shortly that is certainly what we
believe they're meant to do but they
might try to stay I think the police
will then come this is unprecedented
stuff you can't really imagine this
happening at Heathrow can you so a
remarkable 10 weeks of demonstrations
and they're going on K and there is
nothing nothing to suggest they're about
to stop the office a little bit earlier
on Stu it the fact that you wouldn't see
scenes like this at Heathrow and yet we
have seen at police and the authorities
in Hong Kong being pretty heavy-handed
with some of these demonstrators is it
because of the sheer weight of numbers
that they've decided to leave them there
for night
right okay two things okay I see first
of all since I've been here was a week
or two two weeks or whatever I have to
say the police have been very very
relaxed in the way they've dealt with
police stations being attacked not
actually attacking protesters very
violently and in fact one of the big
days last Monday I didn't see a
policeman all day however in the last 24
hours they change their tactics are
being criticized from Beijing they're
being criticized from some of the people
in Hong Kong saying you can't just let
this violence go on and you're right in
the last 24 hours they really change the
way their tactics were they immediately
attack it's it's tear grass straightaway
and then in with the patterns and people
are getting hurt but I have to say the
demonstrators have been pushing them and
pushing them and pushing them because a
lot of them were not peaceful protests a
lot of them are focusing on police
stations thrashing all the cars in the
car park and attacking the buildings
themselves when there are no police
around they say it's a reaction to what
happened in the last month or so but
whatever you say there was no reason for
them to be carrying out those attacks
the police are now decided they're going
to try and restore order you felt
yesterday that the protest movement was
losing some momentum the shooting of
that girl in the eye and what's happened
here today closing the airport I suspect
has reinvigorated the whole momentum of
the protest movement I think things are
just going to get worse and worse to ask
you that just before we let you go
Stuart you covered many of these stories
for us over the years what what's the
atmosphere like how how are you reading
it
what was really interesting yesterday we
went to an area called North Point and
that's quite a conservative area with a
lot of very very hard men in it who were
aggressive to us and aggressive to emen
to demonstrators or anyone who they
thought might be a demonstrator they did
not want them there and it's the first
time we have seen ordinary Hong Kong
people who might actually have a feeling
towards a protest movement but don't
like the violence that be was being
caused it was pretty scary there because
these people were not in for negotiation
or letting anyone pass through their
streets it's definitely changed it's
gone up a notch the police are being
more aggressive the demonstrators are
being more aggressive and now we're
seeing actual other members of the Hong
Kong society taking a position either
for the protesters or against them
obviously it's a civil war but it it's
changed a lot in the last day or so it
will be back to you soon for now thank
you